[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'année
d'interdire pour une émission entière
avec jean pierre dupuy polytechnicien
ingénieur et philosophe bonjour jean
pierre dupuy
bonjour travaillé depuis longtemps sur
la philosophie des catastrophes êtes
l'auteur de pour un catastrophisme
éclairé quand l'impossible et certains
ou d'une petite métaphysique d'être une
amie
aujourd'hui vous publiez la catastrophe
où la vie ce sont vos pensées partant de
pandémie
c'est toujours aux éditions du seuil
est-ce que nous ne nous sommes pas tous
comportés plus ou moins de manière
catastrophique depuis le début de cette
catastrophe
il y à 16 mois maintenant tous faut les
dire à l'échelle de la planète
oui parce que nous n'avons pas été ni
pire ni meilleur que d'autres que
d'autres portes jeudi j'indique dans mon
livre que c'est d'ailleurs évident que
j'ai la chance ou la malchance de vivre
mais pleinement sur trois pays trois
cultures trois langues qui sont le
brésil le pays de mes enfants et
d'artifice c'est pas rien ma famille est
là bas et les états unis d'amérique et
spécialement la californie où j'ai mon
activité de recherche et d'enseignement
et j'ai des attaches très très forte
également avec ce pays et ce peuple
cette lande donc ma comparis ch et dire
la comparaison que je peux faire c'est
pas rire d'ailleurs je n'ai pas choisi à
dessein mais c'est entre deux pays qui
ont sous la gouvernance de deux leaders
pour le moins contestable je veux pas
avoir d'ennuis bon on aboutit à des
résultats assez assez horrible
et nous est donc bien sûr écoutez je
crois que vous n'avez sans doute pas
l'intention de beaucoup parler chiffres
mais je veux quand même donné un chiffre
qui fait réfléchir
bon le nombre de morts par tête
d'habitant les populations france brésil
etats unis c'est à peu près 1 3 5 67
millions de 115 millions trois cent
trente millions on savait pas en trois
sets
regardez où nous en sommes au nombre de
morts bon nous on a dépassé les cent
mille morts le brésil avant le carnaval
ça il faudra parler du carnaval sirna
fait tout simplement c'était de l'ordre
de 330 mille morts et les états unis
contrainte à lâcher le pouvoir
non sans peine c'était de l'ordre de 500
mille peines ses gros seins 3,5 alors le
brésil depuis s'est détaché dans
l'horreur mais quand même
avant dix ans autour de février de 2021
le nombre de morts par tête de pipe
était le même dans ces trois pays
or il ya eu enfin bon je ne sais pas si
on va venir du bien ou du mal du
président macron on va quand même pas le
comparer à bolton arrow watrin alors
comment sait-il que la france n'ait pas
fait mieux que les états unis et le
brésil
ou alors comment se fait-il que les
stadiers et le brésil les frapper mais
ce n'est pas fait pire pendant que la
france mais sous les c'est en gros le
même virus certes y'a des variants il ya
des buts en l et ses bras ses cd
gouvernement donc des gouvernants très
très différents et ont fait un gros
pareil il reste le troisième terme un
dont on parle très peu d'ailleurs en
france dans les commentaires et tous à
savoir les peuples les peuples bon
et c'est pas très à l'honneur de la
france l'art aux états unis si vous
voulez les décisions sont prises
tenez vous bien au niveau du comté 40e'
un compte et c'est en gros la surface en
moyen d'un département français
il ya 58 compter en californie qu'il
fait les trois quarts de la france donc
c'est à peu près un département les
décisions qui chaque fois qu'elles sont
changés en france font pousser découvre
des cris d'orfraie qu'est-ce qu'on ouvre
qu'est-ce qu'on ferme la quelle distance
peut-on se déplacer hors de son délit
chine de son domicile
les distances entre les gens les fameux
gestes barrières etc
ces décisions sont prises au niveau des
comtés et elle change d'une semaine à
l'autre
le cas échéant en suivant en collant au
plus près à l'évolution du virus
nous on est loin de cela est évidemment
donc même sous trump la liste à génie
auront en tout cas la californie s'est
mieux comportée nous alors le brésil
aussi la chose absolument étonnante
subaru et jusqu au carnaval
alors le carnaval de rue si vous voulez
le carnaval cc c'est l'âme du brésil
avec le football l'a fait on peut pas
l'empêcher
on ne peut pas l'empêcher et quand les
brésiliens pour les enfants par exemple
viennent à paris viennent en france
bon ça les fait rire de voir comment
nous nous amusons ans et le carnaval de
rue a été supprimée dans beaucoup de
grandes villes d'origine commencer par
you
mais pas le carnaval qui fonctionne la
nuit et qui se fait dans des clubs de
samba qui peuvent des endroits clos et
ancien hangar par exemple serra qui
peuvent contenir 3000 à 4 des personnes
qui dansent dans un endroit clos
frénétiquement et voilà alors ça
évidemment mais il yad'autres fait j'ai
étudié les les les recrudescence de
l'épidémie au brésil depuis noël un lien
fêtes de noël il ya une fête en janvier
ou février à prendre car natale qui est
le no majo peuple noir
et puis il ya le carnaval donc il cette
année a eu lieu carnaval c'est mardi
gras qui a eu lieu
8 février quelque chose comme ça ou vers
le 20 février je ne sais plus à chaque
fois quinze jours après vous avez
flambées épidémiques terrible on en est
aujourd'hui à 4000 morts jouant quatre
mille morts par jour ce qui est x 365
jours 7 à rythme de a créé un million et
demi de morts par parents d'envoyer mais
là c'est vraiment les fêtes
sinon sinon conseiller de la vie
ordinaire
le brésil n'a pas fait encore une fois
rapporté à sa population
bien pire que nous alors ça c'est pas
trés trés un autre honneur un généreux
mais on sait bien que c'est la manière
dont les gens se comportent en lady de
plus en plus à dire je vois ça dont
l'oeuvre dans la presse dans les médias
vous le voyez aussi de plus en plus on
dit tout va dépendre de la manière dont
les gens se comportent un avec le
desserrement des contraintes actuelles
or mais ça enfin on pouvait lire d'aidés
dès le mois de mars de l'an dernier 2020
évident que ça dépend de la manière dont
les gens se comportent
on pourrait très bien arrêter l'épidémie
si on se confinait vraiment
mais ce qu'on en est capable et est-ce
que c'est souhaitable jean prat dont
jean pierre dupuy vous citer une
infirmière qui dit on ne veut pas
d'applaudissements ou deux repas
gratuits
on veut qu'ils respectent les consignes
bien entendu est évidemment et et on
comprend pourquoi dans ce livre vous
êtes très énervé par tout ce qu'ils ont
pu bafouer la science et la médecine par
ignorance que ce soit les gouvernants
les intellectuels ou la population par
la même occasion mais mais ça dépend des
consignes moi aussi je voudrais qu'on
respecte les consignes et il faudrait
qu'on se respecte les consignes de l'
oms en testant de manière efficace qu'on
ne fait pas en eas en traçant les gens y
compris avec des moyens des technologies
de l'information que nous possédons
aujourd'hui on ne le fait pas je
voudrais qu'on isole l' oms le demande
également on ne le fait pas alors est-ce
que ça n'est pas un peu facile de dire à
la fin c'est la faute des gens qui ne
respectent pas les consignes alors qu'au
fond très souvent les soignants ne
respectent pas toujours les consignes ou
en tout cas d'arrêt ce ne sont pas
toujours d'accord sur les consignes
qu'il faut respecter
les gouvernements ne les respecte pas
non plus etc etc
dans mes et moi même je ne sais pas si
on nous avoir toujours respecté un jeu
là je n'essaye pas de faire de la morale
bon moi aussi j'ai comme tout le monde
interpréter les consignes de manière un
peu lâche parfois mais je suis sûr que
une partie non couverte des décideurs
ont fait de même
bon mais c'est certain que il ya eu du
flou des bébés et des erreurs des bep
voire parfois des mensonges bon dans
tout cela mais on ne parle jamais des
gens fiers de nous
quand j'ai dit les gens je veux pas dire
les autres je veux dire nous comme
peuvent bon j'en fais partie et bien
évidemment bon
enfin si vous voulez ce qui m'a frappé
mois bon pour des raisons x ou y que je
ne vais peut-être pas détaillé parce que
c'est ça m'obligerait à parler de ma vie
personnellement ils ont que j'ai été
coupé de mes proches de mai et même de
mes plus proches pendant 14 mois pour la
bonne raison qu'il se trouve au brésil
et aux états unis et que les frontières
étaient fermés et les doubles frontière
du brésil par rapport à la france à
france par rapport aux voisines états
unis part pour la france la france par
rapport au brésil il pareil pari semble
qu'on amérique menace la france dé va
desserrer un peu les contraintes et que
les américains vont pouvoir venir à
paris à partir du mois de juin sans
avoir à exciper des motifs dit un père
du king lisa on dit en anglais
alors voilà donc je suis resté dans mon
appartement à paris qui est dans un
endroit à chelsea et je ne suis pas
malheureux dans un endroit très bien
placé à paris tout près du jardin du
luxembourg et le jardin luxure bon est
devenu mon nom mon seul mon seul
ailleurs s'il voulait bon alors au bout
d'un an et trois mois ça commence à bien
faire je dois vous lire jardin
magnifique mais je le connais par coeur
toutes ses statuts tous ses coins et
recoins et c'est bon c'est un peu trop
mais enfin il ya bien pire que moi je ne
me plains pas eh bien j'ai vu tout l'été
était dernier bien sûr des des gens se
comportaient mais d'une manière
complètement irresponsable des
attroupements de centaines de personnes
alors évidemment il se trouve que ces
personnes sont surtout jeunes là il ya
un sacré problème effectivement problème
éthique problème politique mais mais
rassembler les uns à côtés d'esso de
boulevard du montparnasse par exemple
dans des terrasses de café
ouvert de manière plus ou moins
anarchique et très proches les uns des
autres par montfort et c'est pas pour le
siècle le virus est bien qu'il circulait
à plein bien évidemment alors ils se
trouvent et ça c'est la source d'un
prenez un meetic et politiques terrible
que ces jeunes il semble que ce soit de
moins en moins vrai ça c'est quand même
très intéressant ne même si attrapé le
virus
ne tombez pas malade et bien souvent ne
savais même pas qu'il s'appelle viry et
mais on peut dire que ils savaient
qu'ils ne savaient pas ils savaient
qu'ils ne savaient pas ce que tout le
monde savait en principe que 40 % des
cas inception général retenu deux sont
des cas un symptôme est mais ayant le
virus
il s'agit forcément de repasser d'abord
les uns aux autres et ensuite à leurs
parents et leurs grands-parents qui
allaient eux mêmes le passé à leur avis
et c'est comme ça que virus a circulé à
continuer de circuler le virus et
circulent pas il circule pas comme ça en
tombant du ciel une circule de bouche à
bouche donné deux narines à naryn enfin
bon est pardon pardon encore une fois de
vous un terreau pour un jean pierre
dupuy mais je vous en prie vous êtes la
mort voilà pour le plaisir de la
conversation mais
on sait qu'on se contaminent en
intérieur et
intérieur et parlée par les aérosols
c'est à dire que les jeunes dont vous
parlez dans le jardin du luxembourg
il ya très très peu de chances qu'ils se
soient contaminés on ne se contaminent
pas directement c'est très très rare à
part non familial bien entendu parce
qu'on se parle très très proches
on s'embrasse et là on se contaminent
mais sinon de se contaminer directement
c'est très très rare et honteux qu'on me
tamin pas non plus
en touchant des objets comme on l'a cru
à une époque
donc en fait on sait qu'on se
contaminent en intérieur par les
aérosols donc en restant très longtemps
au même endroit et pas au jardin du
luxembourg
mais tout le monde ne le sait pas et on
ne nous le dit pas toujours et il ya
souvent des médecins d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui qu'ils se trompent et qui
croient qu'on continue de se contaminer
au jardin du luxembourg
et si vous écoutez les émissions les
débats sur les chaînes d'information on
hurle parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui sait
qu'ils étaient sans masque hier qui se
sont promenés qui sont touchés on sait
que les masques en extérieur ne servent
plus à rien mais ça fait rien les les
médecins aussi peuvent être
catastrophiques non mais je vous
exagérer en disant qu' il n'y a pas de
contamination extérieure
bon ça n'est pas vrai mais alors
effectivement vous croisez quelqu'un
dans la rue et par exemple un joggeur
qui couvrent bon alors vous avez sur
internet vous pouvez vérifier cela des
films qui ont été faits de ce qui sort
de ce qui sort des naseaux d'une
personne si je peux dire mais où sa
bouche lorsque ils courent par exemple
vous marche très très vite
alors ça c'est des phénomènes
d'aérodynamique et si la personne
courent ou marchent très vite
lorsqu'elle éternue lorsqu elle exhale
et cetera
et bien alors il ya des faits domaine
aérodynamique qui font que mr autour de
son visage ne reste pas immobile et que
l'aérosol est envoyé à perpète
bon ok mais je ne considérait pas ce cas
là je considérais des gens
est ainsi très proches les uns des
autres et se parlant à 50 ou 60 cm mais
enfin et là ils étaient vie et sans
masque bien sûr et là il est évident que
ça siens venu d'en faire un voyons c'est
ce qui empêche je répète ce qui empêche
de la contamination cécilia de la
dynamique un peu comprenait pas ce que
les aérosols vers l'espagne mobile
évidemment ils sont envoyés de l'avant
d'ailleurs comme lorsqu'un avion ainsi
que les circuits dans l'atmosphère mais
je parle pas de cette situation je parle
de gens
ainsi les impôts et les autres très
proches les uns des autres comme on en
rit de données très bon dans ce qu'on
discute bon non mais ça c'est alors
effectivement je me rappelle très bien
au tout début les gens et moi et moi
aussi d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'on
rentrer chez soi eh bien on essuyait des
boutons porte jacqueline sedera on
croyait que on croyait que la combi
nation et la cnape à la contamination
passer par le toucher bon on est revenus
là dessus mais on est parvenu
complètement
c'est sans doute qu'il ya des
contaminations par les toucher mais ce
qui est effectivement le plus dangereux
le sait chez soi et ces messieurs il n'y
a pas d'absolu dans tout ça c est et
comment dirais-je
il suffit de regarder le web pour voir
des films de je répète des clés de la
manière dont le virus dans le oui dans
les à part dans les délais les aérosols
passe à travers des masques
d'ailleurs bon ce qu'on n'a pas dit
souvent c'est que les fameux masques
chirurgicaux que la plupart d'entre nous
portons protège les autres beaucoup plus
qu'il nous protège c'est pour ça que je
parle je crois que vous avez cités cela
tout à l'heure d'un virus et tico sens
qui nous oblige à penser aux autres on
est protégé dans la mesure où les autres
se protège
voilà on dépend des autres pour ce jeu
les dire en vous lisant j'ai eu
l'impression jean pierre dupuy que vous
étiez particulièrement sévère avec tout
ce je le répète ion qui ont bafoué la
science notamment les intellectuels
parfois les gouvernants il y en a eu
aussi le peuple comme vous l'avez dit
vous et moi
de la même manière mais je me demande si
vous n'êtes pas trop confiants en faveur
à l égard des médecins parce que au fait
les médecins c'est comme toutes les
professions vous êtes polytechnicien au
début du 20e siècle
tous les généraux de l'armée française
sortait de polytechnique or quand il ya
eu après la guerre mondiale la plupart
d'entre eux ont perdu une bataille
et puis d'autres en ont gagné ils
étaient politique tient aussi j'avais le
même savoir on fire navel km plus de
talent que d'autres et j'ai l'impression
que c'est pareil
parmi les chercheurs parmi les médecins
on peut appliquer un peu bêtement
parfois des consignes et puis au
contraire on peut être particulièrement
imaginatif créatif chercheurs et on peut
trouver donc de faire confiance tout à
coup à la médecine de votre part ça m'a
étonné ça m'a étonné parce que vous êtes
celui qui a introduit vent et lynch en
france l'auteur de la convivialité mais
aussi l'auteur de nemesis médical qui
justement refusé de donner trop de
pouvoirs à la médecine ce qu'il appelait
le biopouvoir et j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez complètement
changé d'avis est ce que c'est le
comique qui vous avez changé d'avis ah
non non mais là aussi vous m'amenez a
parlé de moi c'est mon rapport à la
médecine qui a changé dans une certaine
mesure bien avant le arrivée du côté là
excusez-moi de la copine je vais parler
je vais pas renier tout à l'heure du
vocabulaire que nous utilisons un mais
ça c'est une autre question est donc moi
j'insiste pour dire la copie je dirais
pourquoi tout à l'heure oui c'est mon
rapport la médecine agent enlevé tout
simplement parce que j'ai échappé de peu
à la mort
pour une sexualité j'ai subi une
opération assez extraordinaire bin kim à
fond oui il m'a fait réfléchir dix ans
vous remarquerez vous avez certainement
remarqué que le frais thème de mon livre
ça n'est pas des réactions épidermiques
par rapport à tel ou tel qui qui semble
ne rien comprendre à la situation
le vrai thème c'est d'abord et le
rapport à la loi bon et j'ai
complètement changé de point de vue par
rapport à cela et en particulier je me
suis éloigné de ce que vous rappeliez
qui est l enseignement et delic sans
pour autant bien sûr il est mort en 2002
sans pour autant revenir c'est une
amitié très forte qui nous a qui nous
aviez mais je voulais dire quelque chose
le rapport aux experts aux scientifiques
et cetera
mais c'est pas cela qui est un qui est
vraiment en cause c'est la bêtise est ce
que c'est moi c'est ce sont des choses
extrêmement simple qui semble ne pas
avoir été comprise alors pourquoi je
n'en sais rien mal expliqué mal mal
comprise
je crois pas que ce soit une question
d'information je crois que c'est plutôt
une question de formation et de
formation et/ou aux bases les puces les
plus fondamentales
c'est une redondance de la science bon
je prends un exemple les grecs du temps
de dison du 5e siècle avant notre ère et
coop de cela de la pesc ce qu'on appelle
ce qu'on a appelé la peste d'athènes
s'est simplement pas une peste donc
l'époque de thucydide époque de la
guerre du péloponnèse et sert à l'époque
de périclès
c'est lui qui a inventé une bo épidémie
qui veut dire et puis au dessus d'eux un
épiderme c'est au-dessus du derme et pis
tu as c'est au-dessus de la tombe ses
draps des mythes dénonce au dossier du
peuple alors pourquoi parceque il
observait bien n'avons aucune idée d'une
contagion horizontale pas de quelque
chose qui circulerait de personne à
personne horizontalement
mais il observé comme nous que c'est
lorsque les gens étaient assemblés que
ils avaient le plus de chances de tomber
malade et ce qu'ils avaient lieu à faire
c'était de quitter justement les
rassemblements ça il avait compris mais
ils on avait d'inférer que c'est ce que
tous les gens rassemblés avaient en
commun étaient la source du mal qui les
frappait et ce qu'ils avaient en commun
c'est l'air était au dessus d'eux et les
miasmes de l'air voilà voilà voilà
l'origine du bond épidémie au dessus du
par nous nous avons quand même fait des
progrès et nous savons par exemple ce
qui est une réaction cher bon j'ai
l'impression que la plupart des gens
connaissent mieux ce qui se passe dans
une réaction nucléaire d'une centrale
atomique ali bongo à une bombe atomique
que ce qui se passe à propos du virus ce
sont des réactions en chaîne de
fabrication r le nombre de moyens de
contamination qui a contaminé en 8
directement un match et c'est la
signature d'une réaction en chaîne si ce
coefficient est supérieu re à et ça
explose comme dans une bombe atomique
dont deux dans une bombe atomique ce et
les neutrons qui frappent des atomes de
noyaux d'atomes d'uranium et un neutron
produit plus d'un de tron nous la région
chaîne
bon c'est exactement cela qui se passe
et il suffit de savoir cela il n'y a pas
besoin d'être agrégé de médecine ou
d'avoir un prix nobel de biologie pour
comprendre cela
écoutez faites le calcul 2 x 2 g par de
20 fois c'est depuis à la puissance 20
audi en mathématiques 7 septembre
sahamies ne s'y donc le r est égal à 2
c'est à dire si un contaminé produit en
moyenne 2 contamination mais très
rapidement
vous avez fait vous avez une explosion
tout simplement parce qu'on appelle la
croissance exponentielle et
l'épidermique comme comme celle ci
attend et je vous interromps parce qu'on
doit faire une pause à cette heure-ci
précisément on s'arrête et on recommence
juste après jean-pierre du pur partira
de là la croissance exponentielle
à moins que je me trompe cela fait plus
d'un an maintenant que le coc vide 19
est apparu dans l'ovi crise sanitaire
crise économique comment tout cela va se
terminer aujourd'hui vous avez de la
dette qui est mise vous avez de la
monnaie qui est émise
tout ça pour camoufler le manque de
croissance et dans dix ans les monnaies
seront par terre qu'on ne peut pas créer
de la croissance en imprimant des
billets comme par magie
ce que vous créez ce sont des problèmes
sociaux le système est irrémédiablement
cacif beaucoup on peut que après 2008
les les banques auraient pris certaines
leçons or pas du tout aujourd'hui elles
sont exactement dans la même situation
voire pire les banques sont au dessus
des lois
il n'y a aucune réglementation pour elle
la crise du coc vide a simplement révélé
à quel point le système était fragile
le théâtre du châtelet c'est pas un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec jean pierre
dupuy qui publie la catastrophe où la
vie pensé par temps de pandémie aux
éditions du seuil en jeu faisait
allusion à la croissance exponentielle
d'une épidémie comme celle que nous
vivons des calculs des projections avait
été fait je crois que c'est pas
l'université d'oxford en tout cas
c'était en angleterre particulièrement
alarmiste évidemment elle avait été
faite d'elle mois février en france on
les a prises au sérieux et l'élan france
parle au plus haut niveau de l'état les
grands fonctionnaires
nos fonctionnaires nos technocrates dont
les eaux prises au sérieux qu'à la mi
mars
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils ont
confiné parce qu'ils sont aperçus que ce
qui se passait dans les hôpitaux étaient
en train de confirmer ses projections
particulièrement catastrophique donc
c'est bien là aussi cette cette
ignorance au fond que vous pointez du
doigt dans votre livre
elle touche toutes les classes de la
société la population c et ses élites
oui mais avouez qu'on a beaucoup plus
parlé des élites que de la population
française paraît évident ben oui là oui
enfin je jure qu'il m'arrive de regarder
les chaînes d'information bas de 14 ans
24 ans qui fonctionne 24 heures sans les
nommer
1 on ne parle jamais de la population
alors que c'est pas que je veux défendre
le gouvernement français
tout à l'heure j'ai dit des choses qui
n'allaient pas tout à fait dans ce sens
mais mais mais il n'ya pas que lui
d'ailleurs c'est un système un système
qui fonctionne entre le les leaders
gouvernementaux et les leaders d'opinion
d'une part et d'autre part des gens
justement chacun était un miroir de
l'autre quel miroir déformant de l'autre
en quelque sorte c'est un système qu'il
faut considérer les pentes
c'est assez nous quoi
mais encore une fois je répète ce que
j'ai dit a vu les états unis et une
origine les deux pays qu'ils servent de
référence n'ont pas fait mieux que nous
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire n'est
ce pas alors je reviens à ce que vous
désignez avec le mot exponentielle moi
je proposerai qu'on bannisse parce que
je sais bien ma génération simuler je
sais plus âgée que vous à l'école on
apprenait ça je sais pas moi pour le
brevet quoi à peu près et pas
nécessairement en classe enfin je ne
sais plus comment fonctionne le système
d'écoles français puisque des enfants ou
petits-enfants sont brésiliens donc mais
c'est très jeune qu'on apprend ces
choses-là avait de toute évidence alors
même que tout le monde utilise ses mots
personne ne comprend vraiment de quoi il
s'agit moi je propose d'autres mots
beaucoup plus imagée et j'ai déjà parlé
tout j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
réaction en chaîne tout le monde voit
pas comment c'est à ce moment ça se
passe une expression que j'aime bien et
qui est parlante aussi sondé des
dynamiques auto renforçant tu 1
c'est à dire que plus plus est fort plus
plus faible accroissement est fort
encore ou pour le dire sous les si vous
conduisez une voiture
bon disons une lamborghini ou quelque
chose là-bas qui accélère très très très
fort la face au taureau enfants sentent
exponentielle de son accélération c'est
lorsque l'accélération est
proportionnelle à la vitesse c'est ça
une exponentielle
l'accélération proportionnelle à la
vitesse les jeux propose de parler de
réaction en chaîne de situation de
dynamique auto renforçant ses draps il à
tout le monde qu'on voit à peu près ce
dont il s'agit est exponentielle
aujourd'hui on était souvent explosives
pour dire grand c'est important et c'est
alors puisque je parle du vocabulaire
j'ai fait une à une à une à 1,6 tout à
l'heure j'ai dit que il me paraissait
important
de dire la copine car je fais un pari
c'est que les trois quarts des gens au
moins les trois quarts des gens qui
disent ne qu'ovide croit parler du virus
dans le cockpit c'est pas le viol ni la
commune c'est la maladie le virus il
annonce est vrai difficile mais écoutez
le sida en commettant deux comme
dépassée terrain on parle de sida c'est
la maladie et le virus ans et qui
s'appelle le vih qui veut dire virus de
l'immunodéficience humaine vih mans et
on confond pas la maladie et virus dans
ce cas là ne virus appel sarce s ars
cause 2 bon ok c'est difficile à dire je
l'admets mais je répète que tous les
gens qui disent ne qu'ovide j'en ai la
preuve maintenant croit parler du virus
alors pourquoi c'est important de faire
la différence
ça c'est une question de fond est bien
parce que une bonne partie des troubles
qui constitue la maladie et en
particulier ses brouillards du cerveau
langue leur guise brahim fog et le
brouillard de cerveau qui atteignent des
gens qui ennuie le virus il ya un an et
deux mois et qui ne peuvent pas dire
plus d'une demi-heure après quoi ils
sont trop fatigués mais aussi les
maladies cardiovasculaires et aussi des
poumons
ces choses sont ces symptômes de la
maladie sont lieux parfois plusieurs
mois après que le virus a disparu de
l'organisme
qui est ce qu'il est cause notre système
immunitaire ce qui fait que pour
beaucoup fait pour un pas beaucoup pour
un nombre de savoir avec lesquels je
suis un rapport aussi bien aux états
unis qu'en france monde israël ne ne
devrait pas avoir d'hésitation à dire
que c'est une maladie auto immune
c'est à dire une maladie où le système
immunitaire ne se reconnaît plus
lui-même
c'était le cas du sida cette cartouche
toujours le cas du sénat ou ne reconnaît
plus les organes que j'ai dit pour mon
coeur et cerveau comme appartenant au
même organisme
donc il est détruit c'est comme si le
ciem unitaire repérer une attaque alors
qu'il s'agit du même bonhomme est alors
reconnaître cela il ya des gens très
hauts placés dans le l'establishment
médical médical qui qui ne sont pas prêt
encore à le reconnaître pourrait avoir
des implications au niveau des
thérapeutiques dont on parle peu la part
du vaccin bien sûr mais quid des
thérapeutiques
donc c'est une question importante
comme disait je crois brice parain le la
mid d'albert camus
mal nommer les choses c'est pas le berck
amusé mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde et là je
crois que c'est le cas il ya des gens
très bien dans les médias c'est qu'ils y
sont cette confession
alors moi c'est pour ça je propose de
dire l'aco vide pas si on dit le co vide
on ne sait pas si on parle dahmani ou du
virus voyez ce que je veux dire
j'espère trouver que vous vous avez bien
nommé une chose c'est quand vous avez
parlé du du catastrophisme éclairé et un
de vos livres jeux cités au début de
l'émission et je trouve qu'on en a eu la
preuve de ce catastrophisme éclairé qui
est un concept que vous vous avez forgée
à l'époque quand on a vu des pays comme
taiwan comme la corée du sud
comme singapour au fond qui avait
anticipé la catastrophe qu'il avait
anticipé tout simplement parce qu'elle
l'avait éprouvé une première fois
c'était le premier le sar ce comme on
l'a appelé quand on tirait les leçons
qu'ils en ont eu peur qu'ils ont
anticipé et qu'on a vu des pays comme la
france mais où à peu près tout
l'occident qui eux avaient été épargnés
à l'époque et qui en ont conclu que ça
ne pouvait pas leur arrivée et qui se
sont trouvés face au co vie de 19
alors j'ai tendance à faire là là la
confusion que vous disiez je confond le
virus et la maladie mais enfin qui se
sont retrouvés face à ce virus
totalement désemparé totalement à
préparer et ça a été une catastrophe
en fait on a dû confiner tout simplement
parce qu'on était incapable de faire
autrement pour limiter sa progression
on s'est puni on s'est auto infligée le
confinement parce qu'on n'avait rien
prévu mais catastrophisme éclairé ça
marche et c'est la preuve par les pays
d'asie
alors aujourd hui le parenthèse je suis
très heureux que les deux pays les deux
premiers pays qui ont acheté les droits
de mon livre sont une part le brésil bon
mais là s'est passé à peu près normale
sup et dans la mesure où je suis à
moitié brésilien enfin je suis brésilien
par mes enfants mais aussi la corée du
sud tenez vous bien
la corée du sud a acheté les rois
mourier bon ça ça m'a fait très très
très plaisir bon je sais pas ce que ça
signifiait exactement mais les bons mais
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
sauf que non mais sauf que moi je serai
beaucoup moins sévère que vous sur le
premier confinement d'abord il semble
que pour beaucoup de gens il a été
terrible pour des tas de gens sachent et
on le sait mais font des tas de gens la
surprise a été telle
qu' il y avait le national
comment dirais-je à 10 ans de la
nouveauté des choses extraordinaires
passé on était comme dans un film
moi donc il suprême qui habite près du
luxembourg donc près du boulevard saint
michel
je descendais le voir saint michel de
luxe de jardin du luxembourg jusqu'à
jusqu'à au niveau de notre dame disons
au milieu du boulevard au milieu de
boules hba1c n'y a pas la moindre
voiture
bon c'est des choses et bien je les ai
pas vu moi mais envoyer des canards des
oies de benga palo alto la petite ville
où se trouve l'université stanford aux
gens signent où j'enseigne barre doivent
aussi de 60 km au sud de san francisco
ou devrait on voyait des chacals et
dégaine se promener dans les rues donc
c'est donc le sud est donc je vais
t'aimer chèque le confinement c'était
formidable parce que c'était sans
précédent inédit on a tous vécu au fond
on l'a tous vécu on a essayé de le vivre
de manière positive
mais j'entends par là et une punition
parce que tout simplement des pays comme
la corée comme comme samia pour comme
taïwan comme comme beaucoup d'autres
fonds comme si tu jamais ont réussi à
échapper à ça et on est ont éradiqué le
virus sans avoir besoin de passer par le
confinement
parce qu'ils ont testé qu'ils ont tracée
ils ont isolé
ils ont porté des masques eu très tôt il
en avait l'habitude et puis ils ont fait
du catastrophisme éclairé tout
simplement
mais notre premier confinement a marché
oui le fameux officiant r il est
descendu je crois 0,6 ou 0,7
c'est à dire que c'est on était sur une
exponentielle négative
enfin bon c'est à dire une comme si vous
voulez la décroissance d'un atome d'un
atome
fissiles fissible comme l'uranium en
plutonium 238 tous un peu importe
et ça a marché mais certains d'entre
nous nous prévoyons que si mais tout ça
était est et j'allais dire mais
mathématiques mécanique que si les les
gens se faisaient comme si le virus
avait disparu eh bien ça allait revenir
kirin seconde la deuxième vague je
pourrais dire parce qu'il y en a eu dans
les 3e et rien ne nous permet à l'heure
qu'il est d'exclure la possibilité d'une
quatrième vague pour la france si tu
alors tout va dépendre de ce qui va se
passer maintenant
moi je fais partie de ce bon je vais
faire haïr certainement mais on n'est
pas si rare que cela qui compte qu'ils
pensent que le gouvernement français a
fait une grave erreur en ne procédant
pas à pour la troisième vague donc un
confinement total comme le premier
complet mais au moins tu me mets en jean
klein gifi moi j'ai labouré j'ai
l'impression que le président de la
république emmanuel macron au fond avait
avait en fait peut-être lui la némésis
médical de ilitch auquel vous aviez
collaboré à l'époque c'est à dire qu'il
a dit là il a fait aussi il a refusé au
fond d'eux de confier la totalité de la
santé aux médecins ils cédée au fonds la
santé s'est pas seulement le travail des
médecins
c'est aussi le travail des politiques de
la société faux faux faux c'est ce que
disait nietzsche est ce que vous disiez
un peu vous aussi à l'époque je me
disais tellement que la version
française c'est ma plus humain et
d'ailleurs sont pas trop l'air parce que
je ne sais pas écrire à l'est pas je
veux pas dire que je sais écrire
maintenant et ct et attention c'était
pas une traduction
c'était une création voilà pour le
contexte français que j'ai fait en
collaboration avec ivan et voilà mais
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'ils
emmanuel macron en refusant de
reconfirmer comme le lui
le conseil scientifique à ce moment là
et en dix ans attendait le confinement
ça peut être une catastrophe aussi sacré
de la misère etc etc
sacré du désespoir au fond il prenait en
charge la santé et il ne voulait pas que
ce soit seulement les médecins qui en a
qui ornait la garde mais c'est pas parce
que on ne fait pas ce que disent les
médecins qu'il faudrait faire qu'on agit
bien je veux dire ici finit à il ne
suffit pas de dire je ne fais pas ce que
vous faites ou ce que vous me prescrivez
et donc tout va bien
encore faut-il le faire de manière
informée forme et raisonnée c'est bon
c'est pas et encore une fois c'est pas
parceque un groupe de gens appelons le
le biopouvoir dit qu'il faut faire x
qu'ils ont tort
bon car il ya des choses très simples si
vous laissez passer alors certes il ya
des modèles mathématiques derrière tout
ça qui sont d'ailleurs extrêmement
intéressant en soi et pour un philosophe
à dépister moloch comme je suis ça sinon
à étudier mais enfin il ya aussi
énormément énormément bon sens enfin
comme j'ai essayé de lire tout à l'heure
je cite dans mon livre ce qui s'est
passé en juin en juin de l'an dernier
gêné 2020 en chine la chine avait
complètement des confinée après un
conflit morts évidemment absolue et que
ne porterions pas qu'ils avaient
magnifiquement réussie elle ad confiné
et en juin on a trouvé sur un marché une
centaine de jambes qui avait levé depuis
avril virus
ils ont tous referme tout pour cent
personnes
mais il savait compris mais ça c'est du
bon sens ça ne veut pas de ça n'est pas
de la biologie moléculaire très avancé
enfin vous avez compris que il faut il
faut tuer dans l'oeuf toute
reconnaissance toute recrudescence de la
maladie
pardon
c'est ce qu'il faut faire soul et
d'autres métaphore qui sont beaucoup
plus parlante que de parler d'
exponentielle je ne sais pas quoi
c'est par exemple bon je vais parler
d'explosion atomique
il ya aussi les feux de forêt 1 une
forêt sèche et bien une braise
il simule a suffi à tout embraser un on
passe c'est une des définitions du
hasard je signale en passant de mes
pistes et madame une des définitions
moderne du hasard c'est petite cause
grands effets c'est ce qui se passe on
signe des temps c'est une série qui
prend feu petite chose un mégot etc
vous pensez à notre dame non graves de
notre dame
petite cause grands effets ça c'est des
choses qu'on prenait alors effectivement
ces sont des choses qui sont à la base
de la science qu'on devrait enseigner
aux enfants
j'ai pas moi dès qu'ils ont 13 14 ans
sont capables de comprendre cela petite
cause grands effets c'est des idées ce
que j'appelle les idées de la séance qui
sont complètement méconnu et qui doit
faire l'objet d'enseignement alors je
pense que je vais pas citer de nom on
l'a ou de gamme et aux émissions
scientifiques sur la radio française par
exemple france culture il y en a qui se
sont des gens très compétents mais il y
en a pas beaucoup qui l ont tendance à
être trop spécialistes j'en écoutais une
tout honneur bien c'est l'animateur se
voulait presque plus compétents que ses
ses interviewés enquêter des
spécialistes or c'est pas ça qu'il
faudrait faire je crois cours n'ont pas
informé mais former les gens la science
c'est émettre des idées de ce genre 1
petite cause grands effets alors
derrière tout ça il ya les théories de
la complexité les d'ohrid autorisations
etc à sur lesquels j'ai tant travaillé
et auxquels je consacre un chapitre
important de mon livre au milieu
mais bon mais ça je pense que ce sont
des idées qui sont accessibles à des as
déjà de 15 16 ans bon et c'est ça qui
manque justement mais il y en a eu et je
dois dire ah bon de là il y en a il y en
a une autre qui a eu un certain succès
et et vous combattez dans votre livre
c'est l'idée que la misère aussi tu es
et plus que le virus
c'est quelque chose qu'on a vue qui
s'est développée et qui a été même qui à
mon avis d'ailleurs a traversé l'esprit
aussi du président de la république a
fait qu'il n'a peut-être pas voulu re
confiné aussi strictement ni en novembre
ni en i en janvier février mars
l'idée qu'au fond le confinement en crée
de la pauvreté et que cette pauvreté a
le plus ou moins long terme va tuer et
peut-être davantage que le virus
cette idée c'est une idée qu'on peut
tout à fait admettre
elle a sa logique écoutez aussi dit en
point de vue empirique théorique on peut
montrer qu'elle ne marche pas au point
de vue empirique tous les pays qui ont
mis l'économie avant la santé un soin de
manière permanente enfin permanent sur
moins d'un an et demi ce corner on est
au tout début après tout cette crédit
cement ou alors de manière provisoire
tous ces pays sens en opt-in car ils ont
perdu à la fois sur tant de la santé
carnage et sur le plan de l'économie et
pour une raison théorique très simple
c'est qu'on ne maintient pas on
développe pas on ne sauve pas l'économie
dans un cimetière
bon le capitalisme bon la marcheuse
dirrell capitalisme s'accommode puisque
s'accommode de l'abrutissement des
masses mais encore faut-il que ces
matches
soit d'abord de soi je ne sois pas morte
et deux et soit en état de travailler à
minima puisse reproduire leur force de
travail donc alors je cite quelques
c'est enfin vous les avez en tête que
lui comme moi bien sûr
l'amérique de trump ça à toi le brésil
de molson arous à toi mais aussi
l'espagne et le portugal espagne
l'espagne parfaitement réussi son
premier compliment
et puis venue n'était 2020 non étant
donné que son économie repose en grande
partie sur le tourisme
elle a rouvert ses frontières et au mois
de septembre
c'était c'était le champion du monde de
la croissance du nombre de cas par jour
le portugal a fait la même chose mais
lui à noël sont les vacances de noël les
gens du nord portugal
à noël il a ouvert alors qu'il avait
réussi sans confinement il a ouvert ses
frontières à noël et sa flambée mais
voilà alors évidemment il ya aussi la
suède
donc il ne dépare à jouer ce jeu là ils
sont des records dit terriblement bon et
bien sûr le royaume uni de johnson voilà
donc ça ne marche pas je suis désolé il
ya une asymétrie entre la santé et
l'économie
l'économie a besoin des gens en bonne
santé
et donc voilà la dernière question
jean-pierre dupuy que je vais vous poser
parce qu'il nous reste que quatre
minutes
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent même
encore aujourd'hui
bon ce n'est pas la fin du monde après
tout ça a pas fait autant de morts que
cela et vous de vous appeler ça le
sophisme de l'an 2000 puisque bull
comparé au fameux bug de l'an 2000 dont
on avait dit qu'il allait être une
catastrophe
et puis qui finalement n'a pas hésité
une alors on a dit bon en fait c'était
n'importe quoi on nous a dit n'importe
quoi sauf qu'on a oublié
qu'entre temps on avait dépensé des
centaines de millions de dollars pour
régler le problème avant le 31 décembre
de l'an 2000 et aux faux vous vous dites
que c'est exactement pareil on a oublié
qu'on a pris tellement de mesures contre
ceux contre ce virus que au fond
effectivement il n'y a pas eu tant de
morts que cela exactement ce que
j'appelle une pathologie de la causalité
on oublie tout simplement que si l'état
de santé de nos peuples et papy vient
c'est franchement pas ce qu'on a mis en
oeuvre ces mesures
bon alors la manière de régler la
question c'est de se poser la question
qu'est ce qui se serait passé si on
n'est pas pris ces mesures
évidemment c'est ça qu'il faut qu'ils
aient la question à poser
alors les gens que je critique de ce
point de vue dans de grands
intellectuels ont une réponse à ça il
est impossible de dire ce qui se serait
passé si on avait agi autrement qu'on a
fait mais c'est une réponse est
inimaginable ça veut dire qu'on ne on ne
se pose pas la question
c'est ce qu'on appelle un film je suis
des mondes contrefactuelle ou virtuels
que se serait-il passé si le nez de
cléopâtre avait été plus longs plus
court et c'est bon ça s'appelle et
contrefactuelle n'y aurait pas de
science y aurait pas de littérature il
n'y aurait pas de pause it sans les
contraintes actuelles
or on peut quand même deviner enfin
avoir des intuitions sur ce qui se
passait l'école économique de toulouse
oh pardon et toulouse cool avec une arme
x pour lequel j'ai pas une sympathie
extraordinaires bon écran lieu d'une et
que ce rappel le néolibéralisme avec le
prix nobel jean tirole on a fait quand
même les calculs faille des estimations
en dix ans et et si on est pas si on
avait comme dans d'autres pays
rien fait on aurait vécu comme avant eh
bien on aurait à la fin 2020 1 million
demain en france on sort était
complètement insupportable
c'est donc c'est ça effectivement de
sophis nous allons devenir enceinte
pendant ce dîner
on a fait tout ça pour rien regarder il
n'y a pas beaucoup de morts mais il n'y
a pas beaucoup de morts parce qu'on a
fait tout ça c'est fini c'est un
pathologie logique de la logique et au
moment du bug de l'an 2000 savait était
exactement pareil d'ailleurs c'est drôle
que vous fassiez cette comparaison
j'avais fait aussi d'ailleurs mais
parce que à l'origine de celui le
premier qui est dit faites attention aux
risques y avoir un bug en l'an 2000
c'était bill gates est déjà j'avais
oublié ça c'est oublier que c'est bill
gates les querelles sont là pensais que
ça allait totalement ruiné toute la
forme acquis petit grand système ibm
languereau allait disparaître
à la suite de si rien n'était fait ibm
allait disparaître et donc la boucle est
bouclée merci jean pierre dupuy d'avoir
passé toute cette émission avec nous ça
ne remplace évidemment pas la lecture de
votre livre la catastrophe où la vie
pensé par temps de pandémie
c'est paru aux éditions du seuil on a
évoqué juste quelques détails de tout ce
que vous écrivez dans ce livre vous
parlez d'énormément de chose merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]